extrañas protestas contra los
confinamientos en Beijing
Shanghai
[Aplausos]
o Hong Kong esto en China mientras en el
mundo las manifestaciones se extienden
al frente de las embajadas como en
Londres capital de Reino Unido y Tokio
capital de Japón pero más allá del
malestar los efectos son notables los
principales índices de Wall Street
abrieron a la baja el lunes y la
comunidad internacional empieza a
pronunciarse al respecto así habló el
canciller de Reino Unido bueno las
protestas contra el gobierno chino son
raras y cuando suceden creo que el mundo
debería Tomar nota pero sobre todo es el
gobierno chino el que debería Tomar nota
de forma similar se expresó el gobierno
alemán
hemos tomado nota de las noticias de
protestas en varias de las principales
ciudades chinas también de los informes
de acciones a veces violentas de las
fuerzas de seguridad contra los
manifestantes sobre el terreno
puedo decirles que por supuesto nuestra
embajada en Beijing así como nuestras
otras misiones diplomáticas en China
continúan observando la situación de
cerca la pasada semana a un incendio en
un edificio de urumkie capital de
shinyang causó 10 muertos los
manifestantes argumentaron que las
graves restricciones que impidieron a
los fallecidos escapar y su rechazo se
ha convertido en un clamor cada vez
mayor contra casi tres años de
confinamientos aún así el país continúa
con su política de cero covid